good morning everyone I hope you're all
safe and well and dry at home today is
our last online lesson and I've really
enjoyed having the interaction with a
lot a much broader group of you over the
last few weeks this is not the last part
of MAF two graphing techniques there is
one more lesson on that that we're going
to do tomorrow but you're going to do
that in class with your teachers and
it's kind of a summation of everything
you've learned over the last couple of
weeks in this topic but the last bit of
a new skill that you need or new sort of
concept is about solving inequalities
with graphs and so as an introduction
into this what we're going to do is
think about well solving equations
because it's pretty good at those right
and we're going to highlight the issues
that come up when you try and extend
these techniques into solving
inequalities so let's start over here on
the left hand side with this guy very
simple equation x squared equals 4 now
I'm hoping it's so simple and then you
guys are so far into learning
mathematics in your life that you look
at this equation and you involuntarily
think of the answer like your brain
can't avoid coming up with the answer to
this when you say x equals on the next
line what we want to do is take square
roots of both sides square root of 4 of
course is 2 but hopefully you've also
internalized that when you're doing
something like this there's not just one
solution this is a quadratic so you
would expect there be two solutions a
plus and a minus and sure enough if you
square either of those numbers positive
2 negative 2
you'd get 4 so they both satisfy the
original equation ok so we know how to
solve equations no big deal but I want
to highlight for you that even though in
many ways they're similar inequalities
like of this are different in some
really crucial ways which make the
graphing techniques that we've been
looking at recently very very relevant
and useful let's just imagine for a
second please don't write this down
because I'm about to write down
something wrong this time I'm doing it
on purpose imagine if we were to try and
treat this inequality the way we treated
the equation up above if I were to say
okay well I've got an x squared but I
just want X so I'll do the same thing
I'll take square roots of
sides that leaves me with X on the
left-hand side there's a greater than
symbol instead of an equal sign and then
I say I get plus or minus 2 on the
right-hand side now this is this is
weird because it's not just weird it's
also wrong
it's weird firstly because we know that
this guy up here is shorthand
it's short for x equals positive 2 and
also x equals negative 2 it's shorthand
for both of those at the same time but
when you have a look at this guy I've
written in red which is wrong if you
imagine splitting it off in the same way
it would be kind of puzzling you would
say well X is greater than negative 2
and then X is also greater than 2 now
that's that's kind of weird right like
if I were to draw this on a number line
for example if I drew and I invite you
to have a think about what this would
look like for you if I put some markings
yeah
that'll do me and I said ok let's plot 0
there in the middle of the number line
here's two here's negative 2
what would I or how would I represent
these two inequalities on the number
line well X is greater than 2 will be
this guy over here on the right hand
side from 2 onwards and then when I look
at the other one X is greater than
negative 2 I draw another hollow circle
and then I sort of just keep going right
and it sort of includes the other one
now not only this is confusing it's just
plain wrong if you take some values that
are actually in this part of the region
that I've drawn well let's take a value
like here 1 right and when I put in x
equals 1 does that solve this inequality
up here and the answer is it definitely
does not you substitute in x equals 1
you're like 1 squared that's not greater
than 4 okay something's clearly mucked
up here so this is no good this is not
satisfactory we can't just tree and
inequality the way we treat an equation
there are some parallels like we can add
and subtract the same thing to both
sides we can multiply by a positive
number on both sides and everything will
be fine but when it comes to solving
things like this we have to try a
different technique and that's where the
heading this idea comes into my own
we're going to use graphs to help us
this time
please do pick up your pens and write
and draw along with me I want us to take
this inequality this x squared is
greater than four and I want us to
visualize it with the help of all the
graphing techniques we've developed over
the last couple of weeks this is what x
squared looks like we know that right y
equals x squared gives us this parabola
shape now when we see this inequality
over here what this is asking is when
you look at this graph x squared can you
tell me when is this graph above 4 I
should say when it is it when is it
above y equals 4 okay
y equals 4 is a horizontal line I'm just
gonna draw it in now let's say it's
somewhere around there here's y equals 4
and you can clearly see that there are
two parts of this graph two parts of the
parabola that are above my green line
right and those are the parts that I'm
interested in um you can see there's
this section up here gonna make this a
bit thicker and then you've also got
this section over here both of these
sections of the graph satisfy this this
quality I'm looking for when is x
squared when is the parabola above this
line 4 and now what I want to do though
is I want to say what are the x-values
that make sense of that like when you
had a look at me solving this equation
over here I got X values that were the
solution what are the X values that make
sense of this well what I do is I look
at the portions of the graph that are
satisfying this quality it's it's this
part over here on the left and this part
over here on the right and I look for
the domain of the function that gives me
those parts of the graph ok let me say
that one more time I'm looking for the
domain of the function that gives me the
part of the graph that I want so for
example if you have a look downward here
if I go from this spot over here and to
the left you can see that all the parts
of the parabola that are to the left of
this little corner here all the parts
the left will be up above y equals 4 so
I want those sections right all I need
to know is what is this spot where is
this point of collision now based on
what we did with this earlier
here you can see that's gonna be x
equals negative 2 that's going to be the
value that comes down here so so long as
I am to the left of negative 2 I guess
we would say X is less than negative 2
that part will be above y equals 4 it's
the part that I want then of course if
you look over to the right there's this
other section over here that comes from
this spot going in the positive
direction so so long as I'm to the right
of that if I'm in that domain again that
section of the parabola which you can
see up above here it's above y equals 4
and that's the part that I'm interested
in so again I need to know what this
value is it's two based on that question
I solved before and I want the part to
the right of it so it would be X is
greater than 2 now what I've written in
here let me just higher isn't another
color for you what I've written in here
is my actual answer it's X is less than
negative 2 or X is greater than positive
2 so you can see it's it's kind of
related to what I did over here which
was incorrect but the inequalities are
facing in different directions and I can
tell that because I'm looking at a graph
the graph rather than algebra is going
to be our key instrument for solving
questions like this for solving
inequalities now just before I pause and
see if mrs. lisa has anything to add I
want you to notice that this is not the
only way we can think about this x
squared is greater than 4 I could take
this original question let's go down
here and I could rearrange it slightly I
could say well what about if I subtract
4 from both sides I would get this right
now the reason why I'm highlighting to
do this is because what I'm now looking
at is a a single function over here on
the left and what I want to know is when
is that greater than zero in other words
when is this function on the left when
is it positive now the reason I like
that is because it's really easy to spot
where functions are positive and where
they're negative we've got us a place on
our Cartesian plane that sort of divides
the positive from the negative and that
is the x-axis if you have a look at this
guy
here you can see this is the same graph
it's been translated downwards four
units and what I'm now looking for is
where's the part that's above the x-axis
I don't have to draw some other line
here in green I just look at the axis
which I had to draw anyway and I say
where is the part that is above the axis
you can see it's the same part over here
on the left in this same part here over
on the right and if you go ahead and you
solve this you're gonna get this same
intercept over here negative two and
it's the section to the left of that and
then you're going to get the Incept on
the right which is positive two and
you're going to go in the positive
direction so you can see you get the
same answer but I like thinking about it
this way because I'm really good at
finding where things cross the axis
these are intercepts we've been finding
these for years and years and years so
mathematicians being famously lazy if
we've got a skill we've well developed I
want to hijack that and use it to solve
these new questions okay okay now as
promised let me show you my summary of
this kind of in theory form right if you
want to solve for some function being
greater than zero and you can see right
here that's what I did I rearranged my
question instead of saying when is x
squared greater than four
I said well an equivalent question is
when is x squared minus four greater
than zero if you ever get a question
with the inequality unit do your best to
rephrase her if possible so that the
right-hand side is zero because then
what you can do is solve this question
by finding the x-values where this
function is above the x axis because
above the x axis means that you have
positive values and that's that's what
you're searching for
when is the function positive and you
can see by contrast you will just as
often have the inequality sign going in
the other direction you will need to
know well when is your function less
than zero and the great thing about this
technique is it's very easy to adapt if
you want to solve when the function is
less than zero then again you're looking
for the X values where your function is
not above the x-axis but this time below
the x-axis every time you're below
you're getting negative values for Y so
this is kind of my summary right when
you get presented with in an inequality
and you have to
even when they don't tell you to graph I
would say number one make one of the
sides zero usually the right-hand side
and then graph whatever you have on the
left and look for where it is above or
below the axis